president biden announcing new efforts
to curb the recent rise in violent crime
across our country
as washington correspondent jessie
trunoa reports his plan focuses on
addressing gun violence providing money
to cities that need more police
and offering community support
[Music]
president joe biden is taking aim at
rising gun violence across the country
with a new federal strategy the
president's plan cracks down on gun
dealers who break federal law
and create strike forces in several
major cities to help stop weapons
trafficking
it also encourages local leaders to
invest covet 19 relief funds
into policing it's not just hiring
police officers but it's also
making sure there's funding so that they
are getting trained that they have the
tools needed
to deal with the community in a safe way
and accountable way
to continue that community approach
white house principal deputy press
secretary karine jean-pierre
says the plan also suggests cities
prioritize summer jobs for teenagers
and re-entry options for formerly
incarcerated americans
working closely with them to make sure
that they have a safe summer
chicago is the uh the largest outdoor
shooting range in the world right now
republicans like louisiana senator john
kennedy and tennessee senator marsha
blackburn
argue police departments can't fight
crime if they're also under attack
they point to efforts in some cities to
cut police budgets
in favor of mental health services
housing assistance
and other programs it has demoralized
police forces and it has
emboldened criminal activity
and this is something that has to stop
but jean-pierre says
that's an empty argument the president
has been very clear he does not believe
in defunding the police
in washington i'm jesse tannor